we're going to turn now to a major
decision overseas that could affect gas
prices here at home OPEC plus the
international oil cartel says it plans
to cut production quotas by 2 million
barrels a day starting next month that's
around two percent of worldwide
production and the U.S is accusing OPEC
of doing it at least in part to help
Russia in its war effort here to explain
all of this is National correspondent
Errol Barnett we got him in studio we're
happy about that Errol This is
complicated good morning hey there good
morning look opec's move has a single
goal here to boost falling oil prices
but member nations were already failing
to meet previous production quotas so
this new cut is equivalent to fewer than
900 000 barrels per day but still this
is significant now fuel data analysts at
GasBuddy estimate this quota could lead
to prices at the pump jumping for all of
us by 15 to 30 cents now on average gas
is currently hovering around 380 but
prices have been ticking up in recent
weeks credit note that less fuel makes
energy outputs from Russia more valuable
and opec's decision comes of course as
Russian oil exports face sanctions from
the West as punishment for Vladimir
Putin's war in Ukraine now cartel
leadership insists yesterday this new
quota is intended to stabilize the
market not to bolster Russia still
though in comments to reporters White
House Press Secretary Karen Jean-Pierre
says in part quote it's clear that OPEC
plus is aligning with Russia and in a
statement the bite Administration said
the decision was short-sighted calling
this a reminder of why it's so critical
the U.S should reduce its Reliance on
foreign sources of fossil fuels and Gail
for those who hit their homes with
heating oil this also means a more
expensive summer before you factor in
inflation well more expensive winter I
should say yeah yeah we know what you
meant the hits just keep coming thank
you very much erroll good to have you in
the studio